The joe rogan experience.
We were telling stories this week and about like,
like one time.
Okay,
one time,
one morning I thought I was,
my parents were out of town,
my little sister was 10,
I was probably 21 I was drinking a lot at the time.
So it was,
you know,
party,
Animal Shit.
And then,
and I was pissing a lot of places that like in the round houses,
like I pissed on my ex girlfriend's dining room table and was walked in by her
dad.
Do you want to talk about a fucking nightmare?
Oh my waiting,
waiting,
waiting.
Were you passed on the dining room?
MEDOC her dad walked in and caught her dad,
Larry Medoc in Orlando.
Larry,
if you're listening,
I,
I wa I'm guilty.
I so here's,
Oh yeah cause I never really accepted blame for it.
I always said it never fucking happened cause it cause I didn't want it to cause
I didn't want okay.
Why did you do it?
It was thanksgiving.
It was right after the rolling stone magazine came out.
And so,
and I go back to party on what do you mean the rolling Stone magazine with a
number of the rolling stone in 1997 called me the number one party animal in the
country just for someone who's not,
doesn't know.
And then that was a big deal.
I became famous until I became famous in like Tampa,
Florida,
Tampa,
Tallahassee,
Gainesville,
Orlando,
anywhere that I had people with four went to Florida state lived.
I was,
they knew who I was.
They were like,
cause the fucking party guy.
So if I went out shots,
really we'd any do people put drugs in my hand.
Like it was fucking insane.
I get roof feed,
I got roof.
He'd a couple of times.
So you became like a sort of a celebrity partier.
I became the guy that I'd walk after the,
before the article I was just the loud,
fun,
shirtless guy on top of the bar,
getting everyone in a frenzy.
And then when the article came out,
it was like the fucking lineman would come to the bar.
I drank at the [inaudible] and they'd pull me aside and they're like,
you're drinking with us tonight.
We want to drink with a party animal.
And then I'd just be up with these lines and like four lineman and we'd be just
doing shots and shots and shots and these guys are 350 pounds,
two to 18 at the time,
probably like going through to 18 and probably more like two 25 but,
but and so I became like,
like I say famous,
I say like reality show famous like the way Snookie her first season was,
you know,
so that's how you were in your town and you're in low Tallahassee.
If I went any reg right after that article came out in Tallahassee,
definitely in Orlando,
I knew 40% of the bar knew who I was in Tampa.
Everyone knew who I was back when people actually read magazines.
It's the rolling stone stuff was crazy when that came out.
It was like being famous cut back to how I pissed on my girlfriend's table.
So thank you.
So I that was like unwind and I was like,
that was like untangling a necklace.
So and so we go out in Orlando,
this is right after Thanksgiving when everyone's home.
So everyone I know from Orlando's at every bar,
all in like church street I think is the name of the street.
So we go out and it's fucking chaos.
When my girlfriend,
her sister and her sister's boyfriend,
who was the coolest fucking guy,
and he'll always have weed.
So we go out and everyone's buying me shots.
We're getting fucking hammered.
Her parents had just bought a house,
just bought brand new house just like I ended.
It was their dream house.
We had Thanksgiving together.
We held hands,
talked about how at the table,
how this is everything we've worked for guys as a team.
We saved,
we scrimped week.
Anyway,
we go back to her house and I'm like,
I'm not fucking done.
Like I want to keep drinking.
And this Guy Dan,
he's like,
oh yeah,
me too.
So we get like a 12 pack of beer and we go out to the dock and d and that's all
I remember.
Danny.
Then the next morning we counts everything to me because I might,
she walks in the first thing in the morning,
did you piss on my dining room table?
And I'm like,
no.
Why would I fucking do that?
I'm a grown man.
I don't piss on tables.
You'd like,
my dad said he caught you pissing on her table.
I'm like,
your dad is crazy.
He doesn't like me because I'm in the party animal and he's trying to get me out
of your life.
That's what's fucking going on and you can get out of the fucking room.
You got to believe me.
I'm the party animal.
I'm sure.
Sure
the fuck you're talking to right now.
He wants me out of your life.
Number one party animal,
the country,
but something to the,
yeah,
I'm sure I actually use the words so
you probably had a t shirt of it explaining it.
Aw.
Did you ever think about getting on the party animal tattooed anywhere in your
body?
I was thinking about getting a squirrel with a beer can and a cigarette that
said the party squirrel on at one time.
Who's going to fuck it?
Question two.
So he told me what your 10 to about it.
I pulled you our world.
If I was a cop and I pulled you over and you had a party squirreled Tatooine,
I immediately take you to jail.
I'm like,
I know this guy did something fucked up in the last couple of months.
You've just got to get it out of them.
We just going to sit down and go,
you know what you did?
Just tell me you know what you did.
Just tell me.
We'll all get out of here early.
We'll get you a nice quick sentence.
Just tell me what happened so I don't even know what you're talking about.
Okay,
so she get back in your fucking crazy.
She goes out to the breakfast table where family is.
Oh my God.
How much piss were we talking about here in my head?
It didn't happen in your head.
It didn't happen.
You didn't have blacked out.
Fucking,
I swear to you,
all my children right now,
I laid in that bed,
hold over,
and I went,
how fun then how do you,
how do you know your home?
He didn't fucking sell you down the river.
Maybe he pissed on the table and then said that you did it.
That's why he woke you up in the morning.
He knew you blacked out and then you blame you for pissing on the table.
That's what's going through my head right now.
As I rolled back over and I go fuck them.
Maybe you will.
Maybe maybe that would be called shitting.
But yeah,
maybe we call it a Brian train wreck pong.
Are you smoking a regular cigarette over there?
No,
it's got wheat in it.
Alright,
so,
so Danny,
then the boyfriend comes in and he like comes in and his eyes are like so
excited.
He goes,
I heard you piss on their table.
And I'm like,
no,
why is everyone fucking saying that?
And he's like,
cause her dad walked in on your pissing on the table and I said,
he's fucking mind.
He goes,
man,
he is pretty set in the,
he saw you pissing on their dining room table.
And I go,
Danny,
I don't remember fucking anything.
He goes,
he goes,
well we got these beers,
we went out to their doc,
do remember that?
And I go,
yes.
And he was like,
and I had a joint.
And I go,
okay,
I remember that.
And he's like,
and then you ate the joint.
And I was like,
I don't remember that.
And he goes,
yeah,
I said,
hold this and you ate it.
And,
and then we killed all the beers out there and I go,
fuck,
we did.
And he was like,
yeah.
And then you start piecing back like little things.
I go,
did we get stuck in a phone booth last night?
And he's like,
no,
we got locked in their food cabinet like in their,
in their food closet,
like a pantry because in their,
because we were eating in their kitchen and then this and this.
I start,
remember I go,
yeah.
So like the girlfriend come out,
the girlfriend's coming and it was a sliding door.
So it was we,
we were eating and the girlfriends came out,
the sisters and they go,
you're fucking making a ton of noise.
So me and Danny went into the pantry and shut the door,
but then we couldn't figure out how to open it cause there wasn't a handle.
You guys were hammered and you cite a pantry.
They shoved you in the Pantry to quiet you down.
We shoved ourselves into the pantry so that we can continue eating.
We were like,
we're going to bed.
They left,
we went to the Pantry,
shut the door.
And then I remember sitting in the pantry.
I do remember this distinctly is us being in the pantry thinking we are in a
phone booth,
laughing how hard all,
they had all this food in this phone booth and we're like,
he believe this bull Moose has fucking Doritos in it.
So then that's all I remember.
So then he says to me,
he goes them and he's really adamant.
So he leaves and I lay back down and I'm like,
I can't believe I'm me a frame for this shit.
All of a sudden I start,
do you ever have one of those?
We use,
remember the dream you had last night and I distinctly remember seeing her dad
in his underwear.
In my dream.
I'm like,
wait,
I did have a dream about her dad and his underwear.
That's odd.
And then I was like,
but he was in here yelling at me.
There's not a jury in yet.
She danced with an old man.
No,
he,
what happened was,
and this,
and then I start going,
oh shit,
this totally did happen.
I woke up in the middle of the night,
walked out to their dining room table,
erect and tried to go to the bathroom.
You know how you would kind of try to lean it down.
So I must have been making a ton of noise at their dining room table.
Pissed on their dining room table,
full blown pissed on their dining.
When you're telling me this now,
now I'm remembering.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
I fucking do remember.
You remember being erect?
I remember.
Yeah,
I just remember trying to pee.
You know how when you,
you have one of those nights where you're like in the bathroom,
you're like,
I can't get to like lean forward.
So I'm leaning forward over their dining room table,
trying to Piss,
making a ton of noise,
knocking everything off of it.
He comes out in his tighty whities I remember that because she came back in and
I go to see your dad were tidy.
Whities and she goes,
he does,
why I don't want to,
nevermind.
I mean you can't dreamed I like,
no one wears off.
So anyway,
I dream about tighty whities twenties let's say 26 25 so here's the worst part.
He yells at me and he goes,
where the fuck?
What the fuck are you doing?
And I said,
I'm going to bed.
And he said,
where's your bed?
And I pointed to the dining room table.
I go right here.
And he goes,
what?
So I,
David Blaine the tablecloth,
pull it,
lay on the bed,
on the,
on top of their table because the table,
you pissed him in my own business and my own business in a Superman Cape full of
piss.
Just lit curtain myself over the neck,
go back to sleep,
and he gets me up and walks me into my bed and puts me back in my bed.
And I'm like,
what a nice guy.
We,
it gets so with our relationship was fucking doomed.
Like there was no,
I get up.
That is a nice guy.
He's a really nice,
Larry Maddock is a saint because if that happened to one of my daughters and my
house,
I would have beat the fucking kid's ass.
So I get off.
Would you really man?
No.
Do it like that again though.
I would beat the fucking kids.
Allison.
Passion in your voice.
Have you ever considered acting?
Maybe.